hey how are you guys going on man Talib
Kweli just walked in let me see I always
have to count out loud make sure I have
everybody's my god I always know I
[ __ ] this up a lot so I'm going to
sure everybody's mic is are no Keiko yep
okay two three four Sam yeah you're on
what this is all on the air by the way
he needs to count yes I mean you need to
count right now first order
it's authentic yes yeah I'm not good at
that I always wanted having one guest
off and two guests on so it doesn't he
counts out loud and then Langston after
the show they said yes someone [ __ ] just
wasn't her to talk for 45 minutes and I
think got out think you're something
wrong with that mic at you turn it on
yeah operator error to my again we're
welcome to the show yeah man thank you
thank you guys - a lot of times you like
hey come on the show and then like okay
but it never happens this is the fastest
it's ever happened
yeah I'm you know it I'm in I'm in a
good space right now where it just kind
of made sense you know like um I I just
said what's up to my people across the
whole I'm in this building often I are
doing hip-hop stuff into and you know
Sirius XM and shades toughest stuff but
to do this type of program is something
I don't get to do that often so I was
excited to do it how was the experience
of because we did this is not happening
together oh and you were right before I
don't hear on second I was on four this
is four people on our show and you went
up and I could I heard part of your
story with those monitors outside I
never go in the room before I go on so
you would have been just kind of told a
story yes how did it feel
it felt good it was nerve-wracking you
know because it's like I was like the
only non stand up doing it bad thing I
don't know how often I wasn't that
familiar with the program so I'm not
sure how often they do non stand ups but
for stand-up it seems kind of natural
and almost kind of liberating to do that
type of storytelling thing and I've seen
those storytelling things before um and
I guess now there's like a genre of
people who go around telling stories and
now they compete and I was like who has
the best story yeah but I always it
always seems like the stand-ups the
comics always are better at that it's
sort of like with the spoken word when I
was doing spoke a word when I was first
coming up as great as some of the spoken
word poets were
if a rapper came up he would always be
better right right right right so you're
looking so so was your were you telling
funny stories I tried to make it funny I
did I told a story that was interesting
and had celebrity guests in the story
yeah had like rock star [ __ ] going on in
the story and I tried I tried to make it
as funny as possible and I felt like I
got some genuine laughs some of the last
four forced but also had it you know
they ended it so all the last one
genuine it's hard though I'm a bad
storyteller like and I bet what I bet
idea was actually a bit it's a true
story but it was a bit in my act that
I'd been comfortable with when I'm a
horrible storyteller there's an ability
to do that some people have and I don't
have I don't know where the important
parts are I rush because I'm panicking
like it's a it's a hard thing to do to
tell a good story
back over details I'm good at it on
paper you know I'm good at rapping but
I've never been like a storytelling
rapper biggie Slick Rick those are the
great storytelling MCS um but you know
III can write I can write my thoughts
out very well I'm good at narrative and
I'm working on like historical fiction
now for the first time in my life which
which is now like a you know like
blowing my mind that think the places
that death taking me you know right on
so um the storytelling is something that
wasn't a natural experience for me but
is something I definitely want to do is
it difficult to go into a room like that
because people who know you are kind of
ready for like something socially
conscious everything has to be socially
conscious socially conscious and
sometimes I would imagine you kind of
don't want to be socially conscious for
a second not I mean yeah at this point
you know in my career I'm 42 years old
at this point so I'm comfortable enough
in my skin that that has been an issue
in my career with making records and
when I started to blow up as an artist
and I had a chance to really compete
with some of the the more decadent
hip-hop artists yeah there was there was
a little a little time in my career
where it's very seductive to want to
make a hit record for the club and
certainly I what I wanted that because
when I when I started my career as a
rapper I didn't start my career saying
I'm going to be the socially conscious
rapper I want to be a famous rapper you
did yeah I didn't want to I didn't want
to just be rock him I wanted to be LL
Cool J right I want it to be have fun
and party in the club like that's what
you know that's what it was about but
the hip hop that I
popular when I was coming up on it it
coincided with the lessons I learned in
my home my parents were very socially
active and socially aware and conscious
like that so they both worked for your
daddy your mom is a professor and yeah
yeah it was right okay yeah they both
are and I'm and so hip-hop at that time
you know that there was a time and
hip-hop where it merged like a perfect
storm like the best rappers the most pop
popular rappers were also the most
socially conscious rappers right and you
know rockin Big Daddy Kane around that
era crs-1 harris was probably the best
example because he kind of he kind of
lasted the longest out of all the
socially conscious rappers and there was
a period where Kerris one had a hit
record for 10 years Street you know and
that was very hard as a socially
conscious artist but then you know nas
became so si
and then it went you know to jay-z and
and and and then to parking and then it
went it became more Street and more
gangster more gangster oriented and that
you had to had that street elements
because of the best and that made a lot
of people move away from you know the
consciousness so when you hear like when
when jay-z puts out that song on the
Black Album where he says he would like
to be you you're sitting there thinking
why would I wanted to be you and right
yeah that's a good that's actually at
very accurate I was like can we trade
places for a second I can maybe have
your bank account for a day and I'll
flip it
um no jay-z I mean you know all due
respect to jay-z jay-z is infinitely
more rich than I am and infinitely more
popular than I am but he you know he's
referenced me and song and if you listen
to his new album yeah Jay I've always
been a fan of jay-z's so much where I
said jay-z will get the real jay-z when
he doesn't have to worry about
fourth-quarter sales when he's
comfortable in this and and doesn't have
to worry about whether or not people
going to buy the record when he's
already rich that's we're gonna get the
real jay-z and that's what we're getting
now he's rhyming about his relationships
and his babies and he's any sampling
Nina Simone twice on the right yeah you
know my biggest record isn't Nina Simone
sample you know years ago jay-z said I
will you know I want to wrap my quality
in common I felt like now he's getting
to yes I mean it's a super like I think
some people were even taken aback with
the new jay-z album because there aren't
any real like bangers on it it's all and
it's very common as songs you like sing
along to really they're kind of like
it's a more vulnerable ham kinda yeah
it's grown and I'm you know there was a
couple of websites talking about jay-z
made the first grown hip hop out maybe
the first grown hip hop album for people
who aren't familiar with hip hop but
that sort of a race is a lot of the
artists that were jay-z himself has
referenced as inspirations for what he
did now he even put out a playlist last
week when almond Rock of the artist he's
been listening to to show you like
listen I'm influenced by other artists
layers there's artists out there that
have been making that type of album but
jay-z is like so rich and famous that
when he does it is like now everybody
pays attention and he's just [ __ ]
brilliant at the craft too but so when
get by blows up are you chasing
like what's the next get by what's the
next wave like I want to get the next
big because that was like that song was
what you were just talking about yeah I
was like the biggest rap song of the
moment when also
oh it was what you do right I mean I
would I would be lying to say I didn't
you know I would be lying to say if I
wasn't trying to at that point in my
career chase another hint and after
goodbye I might I've had two or three
songs that all love songs have to get by
never never a conscious long but like I
died like hot thing blew up and never
been in love and then come here when
Miguel was like a semi hit but nothing
none of them were as big as goodbye
right um which is which is telling you
know it's not like I haven't I put out
other conscious songs as singles but
there was something about get by with
the gospel hook and Kanye was blown up
at the time and he did the beatin he
wrote that hook arm you know it just it
was just a great moment in my career and
I take a great moment for him whatever
happened to just ice let's get down to
it and now you showing you New York City
whoo yeah I'm old right just just magne
bringing out productions he was the
first like drug dealer rapper you know
saying he was the first dude that was
rapping that also has treat cred at the
same time this would be like Boogie Down
Productions I feel like started gangster
rap you know Sam with that and with a
scholar ocular shot he was shot and him
and correct chaos we're doing them you
know criminal minded and then gangster
rap of course blew up in the West Coast
and they did it very well you know
saying but but yeah man that just dices
original booking out production crew
shout out to DJ d-nice who still out
there doing his thing shot out the
cameras you know did they used to be
like years ago when guys would kind of
would [ __ ] with each other it was a
different like I remember they would
have like DJ red alert and Marley Marley
going back and forth but it was all kind
of people [ __ ] on each other but was
innocent to a certain degree and then it
kind of got violently about music yeah
about how you stole my rhyme in your
sucker you know it was right but then it
is something kind of changed well you
know the problem is that these people
come from impoverished communities and
they come from communities that already
have issues and so when you see the
violence in hip-hop is not necessarily
because hip-hop got more violent but
hip-hop just got bigger and you had more
of a street element coming in like kara
resident Karras was homeless you know
sound like these guys were from the
street there was real violent gangster
[ __ ] going on the Zulu Nation you know
there was some citizen violence [ __ ]
going on Zulu Nation came out of
a violent environment you know in the
Black Spades and all the street gangs in
New York City like when you see the
Warriors the movie two worries is a
cartoon version but it was really like
that for a lot of people
was it really somebody on rollerskates
so there was no pad no there's no Liz
knees in the baseball fury I mean it was
a century you know is eccentric because
the style was influenced by by the
popular icons of the time George Clinton
and Parliament Funkadelic you know you
see an early hip-hop Georgia Grandmaster
Flash and all they're trying to do
Parliament you know zan like so it was
flashy but it was it was some gangsta
[ __ ] going on in New York back in the
day and hip-hop comes out of that
hip-hop hip-hop itself is it is a
response to cuts and music programs in
the Bronx and cuts in in after-school
programs and social programs and these
kids were in the street while in all
they had was the gangs and so the Afrika
Bambaataa Kool Herc and all them they
plugged into the lamppost and they
created a culture and then as culture
that is like folk music even though it's
urban industry and it was mostly black
and Latino kids it spoke the language
that people speak in the street now
so anybody of any race creed culture
religion could relate to it you know and
and I think that's what made hip-hop
such a global phenomenon and it made it
so easy for hip-hop to be taken over for
advertising because people can relate to
it so much it's where we watch guys -
who did really well for a while and then
they sound the same as they did many
years ago and it just seems like wow
things of the shine has passed so much
yeah I mean with any form of music yeah
yeah so cool yeah yeah you should have
adjusted a little bit you know if you
could yeah it's tough though because
there's just something it's a gift and a
curse because you know you got to art
you got a group like Gang Starr you know
like recipes to do but like for ten
years they made sort of the same album
just different versions of it and
sometimes you want that but as a
musician you get you get as soon as you
start making money you have resources
why wouldn't you want to use all your
resources
starts out sounding like four kids in a
garage right and then a couple hours
albums later they got the wall of sound
and they have Indian influences and it's
like they're doing it and that happened
to just about every big rock band and
including myself like I came out doing
one style and then I got money and I got
access to people I wanted to work with
now I have a relationship with Pharrell
and I have a relationship with married a
blog and I
I want these people on my album you know
III had a meeting with sting I almost
have sting I'm out there like what did
you say to him and when you try to get
him out super super drunk I was at a
party so we're like a holiday yeah a
party but I said I have a song of my own
beautiful struggle where John Legend is
singing we sampled on every little thing
she does is magic the police record and
we did a song called around my way John
Legend sings a beautiful hook but before
I got John Legend I'm like I'm gonna get
sting to sing on this and like the
president of my label at the time put me
in a room with sting and I'm explaining
the record to him and he was just sort
of drunk nodding at me no it's like yeah
we'll totally do it yeah
you know but I could tell it was like
this is the last time I'm ever going to
do that what could you tell you just do
like this is one of those things that
he's presented with a lot of things
right and this is just going he's not
yeah I mean he's staying he's famous for
like [ __ ] for hours yeah like he has
other things on his mother yeah cancer
sex yeah he's already someplace else it
is amazing how that everyone knows about
that hem is Trudy [ __ ] that they
don't come okay but that's why you got
to get in front of what people say about
you whether it's good or bad you know
like like like like I always get in
front of people always are putting
rumors out and stuff and people
sometimes say quality why do you pay
attention I like because the story the
perception becomes a reality
sting might come in two minutes we don't
know you know they're like the story
right you just let it be though you know
oh yes I can ask for stuff like that
like I I'm nervous to ask a performer to
do something I mean I've done it before
and it's actually worked out but you're
not you're not nervous said hey I want
you to be on my album um you know what
my peer group is easy because I've
developed a level of cultural currency
and respect like there's there's not
many rappers that I can't call and asked
whether or not they'll do it is a
different thing but I feel like I just
any rapper in the business I can call
and ask but another genre music you know
I don't know if this person is familiar
with me I don't know if they know what
what my relevance is you know is like
you know like like you know I be York
that's an artist I'd love to work with
you know that's the Mighty One like man
because she's somebody you can't even
think about what genre she's in she's
just her own genre after she's done a
couple
pop dated thing she dated a DJ at one
point she worked with the RZA at one
point but she hasn't really done a
hip-hop record and I'd like to do a
wreck so if I see her I probably fangirl
out if I see her Oh yours you know I've
got being like nervous you know try to
approach her you know but which it
relationship like with Kanye now because
like when Connie first came out you are
on the first album he was producing your
songs like he was shouting you out on
other songs like are you guys still well
Kanye Kanye I consider I to the day I
consider Kanye a great friend yeah I
think he's an icon he mean he'll tell
you himself he's an icon a genius and
happen to agree um you know I think he's
literally given me life that's what
that's a cliched phrase oh this thing
gave me life is like Kanye literally
gave me life you know in the studio his
energy on tour he's produced some of my
biggest records um she's been
instrumental to my career not just in my
career but to artists like me like most
def and common and Lupe Fiasco and other
artists and he's landed his ear to sound
too um I don't I'm not a trump supporter
at all and I'm not a fan of Trump and
I'm not a fan of artists standing with
Donald Trump so when he when he when he
stood with Donald Trump at least
publicly I was disappointed by that and
I don't have a relationship with Kanye
Kanye is like a super famous
stratosphere out there like he's
achieved a level of Fame that I have no
relationship with yeah so I don't that's
not like I can get him on the phone at
this point I could maybe two years ago
but I can't right now but Kanye
complained last year about not being
able to get jay-z info he complained
publicly on stage right I remember right
so when he complained publicly a stage
about not being able to JSON the phone
that made me feel like I could publicly
say something to him right so I publicly
said listen the Trump stuff I'm not I'm
not I'm not with that but beyond that I
mean look the man is an icon and he's a
genius and and you know if I can't be
honest with him about things that I
disagree with him about I can't really
be a friend Kanye said a lot of things
that have upset people mm-hmm
then I was able to and I haven't agreed
with everything you said but everything
he said up to the Trump thing I rode
with him more like maybe I don't agree
but I you guys are right to say it in
there that's the one thing that I that I
luckily was like I'm not I'm not really
feeling a minute could you get jay-z on
the phone
mmm it might take a month jay-z was on
the remix forget by so I you know I I
met jay-z at a the roots did a Lincoln
centered thing right as get by was
blowing up and jay-z was like my
favorite at the time and I met him
backstage and there's there's like
footage this footage on the Internet of
the first time I met jay-z and me like
fanboying out over jay-z like is like
jay-z me and me and we're showing each
other mutual respect and I'm super
nervous and it's like 10 years ago so my
closer super big then falling off of me
and and then I'm asked him to be in the
song and we exchanged two-way pager Wow
like the vision yeah here we like a
machine let's line it up with the
machine yeah and we exchanged two ways
and I'm I hit him like for like three
months maybe four times to the point
where I felt like I was being a Bugaboo
and I left it alone and then one day in
my email one day he sent me a two-way
page and said I'm gonna eat what your
email my email you this this verse and I
looked at my email the verse was it we
never had a conversation he just sent me
the verse and then I saw him at a party
and I thanked him for the verse I was
like I'm gonna kill me what giving you
the verse I guess for you yeah I was
like how much is that how much he was
like I'm not going to charge you because
you can't afford what I charge for
versus well I've had women say that's
another what is that said if you charged
who does he charge each are just someone
who he doesn't have the same level of
mutual respect I guess like he just
wanted to do it he probably liked you
and wanted to do something now he he
said he told me he said about charger
that would be your whole budget yeah I
know and he was right and so but then
the record came out and it was on the
radio for like two weeks and jay-z was
still signed at Def Jam at the time
Lyoko and heard it and sent a
cease-and-desist out so they had to stop
playing the record why because that's at
that time he was a Def Jam artist so
liriko was like what does jay-z do one
on this underground rap record like nah
you know I'm not on yeah yeah how the
labels do like so that's I think stuff
like that and that jay-z was like I need
to have my own and right I need to own
Rockefeller I need to have rock nation I
need to all title I need to be able to
make my own decision that remix became
huge on mixed
right Sammy I feel like I've heard that
the remix yeah remix adding much it yeah
I got on official never been released
actually that's not true I think I
released it uh like [ __ ] Def Jam like I
released it like a year ago on my
website quality Club calm yeah and but
on but yet up until like you have you
haven't have you even heard that remix
in your family original song I remember
right yeah I have a 98 West's most def
Busta Rhymes jay-z and it avail other
remixes one with Snoop Dogg and it was
50 cent like a bunch of different rings
does that suck so you get jay-z on
something and some dope it a label as to
records like Jesus oh yeah I can open
everything up it definitely sucked it
was it sucked so that's why I didn't go
out at the time that's why to release it
years later right right right I mean you
know people still played it like that
that's the record like when I if I go to
the nightclub haven't I don't go to
nightclubs as much I used to yeah but if
I go to the club that's most likely to
record everyone when I walk in the door
did to Kanye the Jays II get back to
they put or they put your record on when
you walk in yeah every once a while like
it was it is it drunk like I don't go to
strip club as much as I used to but I
used to go to strip clubs and then I
would walk and they don't get by which
is like the strippers I want to dance to
get by so ironic by like I've watched
rippers like goodbye I'd like to go to
the DG look just take it off put on to
change zone just put on such awesome
yeah it's embarrassing if you've like
your own stuff is playing with people in
the world I would hate that if I walked
in and actually if the message was
opposite of what survive in the club one
half you listen to the song yeah compete
is funky and all but people will just
tell the DJ like I just yeah I don't I
don't like the DJ's playing goodbye when
I walk in a strip club to get by is not
a strip club record there are people who
work hard and make a good strip club
record and there are good at it they
should play those records what was a
young Kanye like to work with the same
as Kanye now David was saying I mean
that that's the beauty of Kanye is when
I met him like this is a real story like
when you talk about speaking truth to
power
you talk about like like like like just
controlling your fate I've watched this
man create his own destiny like I
watched him say I'm going to be known
for wearing more polar than anyone
and I'm going to have the bear as my arm
cover my first college dropout my second
I was late registration the third was to
be called graduation he said all it is
before he had a record do you know he
was like you played me jesus walks he
played me I'm hey mama he played me all
these records and I'm like yo this house
this record is great his economic I'm
gonna get a deal I'm gonna put this at
this song on my second out crazy you
know saying like he had it all mapped
down yeah he knew he wanted to do yeah
exactly and that was inspirational to me
because I was I was famous before Kanye
before 50 cent and I remember 2004 they
both came out and they were both huge
and they were competing and the records
against each other and these were both
artists who were referencing me and I
was like okay seeing how they planned
their [ __ ] out it just made me work a
lot harder and sort of reinvigorated my
career I was closed I wasn't as close to
50 at all but I was close to Kanye and
seeing them seeing how they planned it
out really made me say okay I got to
revisit what I'm doing yeah when you see
guys coming up behind you who are doing
something and then and then there's a
smarter way of or they're doing the
business center with it he's like [ __ ]
right yeah there's a lot more stuff to
be done right when you watch guys who
are doing it well right definitely I
mean Tonya he took what Kanye was smart
about is he there was there was a divide
before Kanye Kanye closed just divide to
a large degree and then Drake came after
him and did it again after him but there
was a huge divide between with what
jay-z and then we're doing and what me
and mos def and people were doing and
and there was a mutual respect between
artists leading a considered divide but
the industry in the media made a vine
and Kanye was like he would literally
say in a song I'm rolling with jay-z and
aim - but I'm listening the mos def
equality and I'm wearing a backpack like
a backpack wrapper but it's a Louis
Vuitton backpack right and I'm saying
like he was definitely deliberately
saying I don't have to choose between
these different types of artists but I
miss what was I'm influenced by at all
and they would brag about putting you
guys on the same songs right yeah doing
that yeah yeah
sounds like a fun existence the
microphones sound tending to anybody
remind say that one's over modulated and
I think you turn that one down too much
I kind I knew I shouldn't touch yeah I
didn't need to be touched and that one
needs to be turned down a lot okay
sometimes driving sound engineer yeah
yes well I didn't turn it down turn it
down come to Apex tech I was wrong
yeah that's that yeah yeah yeah you got
to make the first call I thought Samms
Mike was that pot Mike you know idea to
be down it's way over modulating yeah
yeah Sam uh Morelle
okay I thought yes yes all right good
Mike and so yo confused with the Sam's
too yeah so I when you talk about
getting in front of things like rumors
and things like that I thought about a
couple of things number one how active
you are on Twitter but number two it did
it drive you crazy when Twitter
suspended you you were like I need this
I need to avoid I can't be off Twitter
right now that's funny I was I was
suspended from Twitter for an hour and I
think and I like to kiss work I like the
people who Twitter jack and all them to
verify this but I think I'm the only
person in history resurrected from the
dead because you don't hear that it's a
wrap
yeah you know the guy my little age not
coming back say like so you can
suspended it's a wrap
I got suspended and then and then the
people the outcry was so great that they
brought me back within an hour and when
they burned that I had zero followers
but then it took them two days and I got
all my father why did they suspend you
so hmm try to give you the Reader's
Digest version
um as Sam correctly correctly pointed
out I'm very active on Twitter and I
don't know if you've noticed this but
there's a lot of people listen to this
show that don't like me pretty much they
don't like us either I guess when you
when you posted that picture a couple
weeks ago it was like what the [ __ ] are
you doing with that guy and then when
you know announce the show they were
like you know what but to be fair I was
on your Instagram last night and when
you posted the photo your fans were like
no not that guy right there yeah and my
very hurtful vice versa
right right which which is why I put my
Instagram post was this is about to be
interesting yeah right it says because
there's gonna be an interesting
discussion but Twitter I'm very active
with Twitter and in case people a lot of
people fetishize hip hop there are a lot
of people who grew up in the racism at
the status quo in America America has
never been his honest about her history
with racism we try to say everyone's
colorblind let's sweep it under the rug
instead of honestly dealing with our
history I feel like in Germany like they
put historical things on this [ __ ]
Street post and you know you cannot as
illegal to have Nazi
[ __ ] like they deal with the history in
a realistic way and America you have
people talking about as patriotic to fly
the credit defect Confederate flag which
is you know highly offensive for people
of color um on Twitter I'm this I'm my
tweet mirror my lyrics so I've never
done an album that's not about black
empowerment social justice uh you know
all these issues I talk about what the
names of my group was black star right I
like it's like so people fetishize
hip-hop they love the music and not just
for me but it's for groups like Public
Enemy groups like people like care is
one a lot of white fans who like to beat
they like the flow they like the music
but they don't hear the music or they
don't have the information about the
lyrics I'm here with Eric B and Rakim
are saying and then some of that stuff
this is a little jab right there right
there was a 5% use and so 5% philosophy
is definitely like like like super super
hood black political speak the whole
white people lived in caves thing oh
yeah there's a mythology with with with
the nation Islam and 5% and and and the
vast majority of people who are into
that they have discarded that mythology
but yeah there's still some people who
truly believe the white man of the devil
and as was grafted from from dr. Yacouba
yeah and all the stuff that WD fart when
he first came to America is supposedly
all that stuff so so besides all that
stuff because I'm not 5% so I'll add a
five percenter defend himself but um I
speak honestly about race issues as I
should as a black man in America and you
have a lot of fans who they're not
saying they're fake fans they might have
heard Kanye say my names they might have
heard jay-z say my name they like
goodbye um they like mos def mos def is
very charismatic charming performer and
artists they have no I'm associate with
mos def they know that they make good
music but the net they didn't know what
the politic behind it is they didn't
know what I was really saying so now
they see me on Twitter and they're very
upset because they're like this is not
what I remember you might be but they're
incorrect because that's exactly who I
am and exactly the delivers
have always been and I pride myself on
consistency um
and so people come at me in a way where
they get very upset about tweets I never
sent it
you know and like they feel like they're
bullied by my opinion and this is a
problem we have in America and in race
relations with America is that is that
white people in this country have not
had the same racial experience everyone
has a level of privilege you know like
there's all of us in this room were are
we're all born in America in this room
remember we all born in where we have
American privilege and we go to a
war-torn country and [ __ ] gets heat hot
we can run to the American Embassy and
we're good like as Americans we have a
better statistically chance having a
good life you know say like but we all
have a privilege to recognize I have
American privilege I have able-bodied
privilege I have a certain class
privilege because I'm born to
professor's so I was able to get a good
education these are things like I can't
take for granted if I take this into
granted I'm an [ __ ] and when I talk
about these privileges people take take
personal offense to it and think if I
speak about white privilege I'm saying
that all white people are racist or that
all white people have great lives and
that's because people have a study
sociology I've realized that on Twitter
that when I'm talking to people I'm not
talking to people who study sociology or
study critical race theory or even it
had a black experience so I understand
the ignorance so Michael I start to
question these people will explain
yourself explain and when asking people
explain yourself often it turns into a
very racist thing most of time their
closet races they didn't know their
races but everyone's why I get neo-nazis
and white supremacy and overtly racist
people with trying to be racist part of
the problem sir is when you talk about
race everyone is invested in winning
like people are invested in winning the
point even if you eat like you'll hear
someone say something you're like that
kind of makes sense but that you're
already in it and you somehow defending
your team yeah and it becomes like this
thing where it's about winning the point
not about listening to the other person
right it's also I think and I've seen it
happen with with with athletes I've seen
it happen with rappers like when black
excellence is talked about or black
owned business or black control this or
whatever a lot of white people take it
as like they're feeling excluded you
know what I mean and so all of a sudden
it's like no no no no what you what yeah
it's a no it's a bit what
yeah and it goes back you know we have
we have as you know we have Little Italy
we have Chinatown we have you know st.
Patrick's Day parade we have all these
things that people celebrate their
culture and they should then here's the
thing that I think there's a thing that
the racist and the people who are
moderate who in my opinion who don't
mean to be racist but sometimes are and
the socially conscious people that
people find for just so suggests and the
people to the fringe of that community
who are the the extreme the black
nationalists of black supremacy
everything one thing everybody can agree
on who study the issue is race is a
social construct race is not real we're
all the same human being with the same
blood we have the same you know we're
all the same thing
race is a social contract that was
invented during the Atlantic slave trade
during when these Europeans were taking
people out of Africa and it was greedy
you agreed economics money and they
needed to justify the agreed
so they said being a black man being a
[ __ ] is the least valuable person you
can be that's not obviously that's not
real but these disc social construct
that was set up at the time when America
was being born and that America gained a
lot of power from slavery like from
America became a first very quickly of a
world power because they had they were
kidnapping people and making people work
for them for free that's that you become
very rich people don't get paid so now
this is the status quo and no one's
dealing with so to go back to your
question right I get trolled heavily by
people who go the extra mile to talk
about my wife and to put pictures of my
wife up or to talk about my kids and why
your wife and kids because when they
lose an argument to me like you said
it's about winning all Republicans to
get mad about okay they lose an argument
to me because I'm very consistent with
my points and I don't argue I don't I
don't know I don't gonna speak on it so
arguing on Twitter is so hard because
you know people it's 140 characters and
people just get bad fast
right but it's perfect for me because
I'm a rapper right thinking couplets I
think it's a bar listen you know yeah so
that's I think that's what frustrates
people I'm very good at that and a fish
to water that's why I'm on it so often
yeah I jump on and I'm just very within
very succinct and very efficient with my
responses and someone who wanna speak to
you usually hasn't thought their point
out
and I'm asking to explain himself so
then they'd be like okay well your mama
and it become something about your
mother and then this guy posted like
there's people post my mom's picture and
one guy posted my mom's address but this
guy started talking out all the sexual
stuff he's gonna do to my mom and so I
wrote to him this will end bad for you
and you can you can be found and this
wasn't bad for you right I got suspended
for that tweet which was upsetting to me
because I had people talk about they're
gonna come to my house and shoot me
I've had people took my [ __ ] died hang
you're a monkey I mean I've had violent
that's not even I've had violent threats
that I've I stopped reporting years ago
because I would report that and nothing
happened what I do now is if that I get
a guy get a violent like that every day
what I do now is I tell other people to
report because I have a large platform I
mean look at this account report this
guy so it's a guy that was a guy who is
threatening to go and do [ __ ] your
mother ever say well how come he's not
getting well that was the point so I got
suspended he did not um because I'm so
celebrity I haven't I have a degree of
earned celebrity privilege because I'm
celebrity I was able to call certain
people and email people at Twitter and I
was just regular Joe Schmo on the street
I'd still be suspended right now oh and
I'm saying I got back on because I was
able to make certain phone calls and
emails and I was able to present my case
I was able to be like look at these
tweets look at why I said this and then
they suspended that guy and they they
brought me back yeah yeah I've never
been suspended but I've had I've had
those knocked down those notification to
the fights because it's like even if I
win who cares like I think we talked
about this it's like it's not even
satisfying to win the argument whether
it's about race whatever it doesn't feel
good to win in a winner yeah you're
right it's no winning but I think for me
the thing is and and I know that this
may not be a popular opinion with
everybody but we don't have that we
don't have the luxury in 2017 to ignore
online bigotry you're right there's no
winning argument as a lot of ego and
posturing and everything like that but
when I'm speaking to those people I'm
not speaking to them because they're not
on my level and I tell them all the time
I'm not debating you I'm exposing you
and sometimes I'm teaching you I debated
peep I debated Lupe Fiasco on Twitter
because Lupe I see as an equal if I get
on and me and Jim get into some I'm
going to have a debate with Jim whether
we
we are not could I see him as my equal
I'm like okay this is a guy who has paid
his dues so guys made a name for himself
people I respect respect him he's
brilliant at his craft so we may not
agree on everything but I'm going to at
least arriver enough respect to him to
have a debate with him like this random
and not anonymous cowards who clearly
have never traveled the world never read
a book never studied [ __ ] haven't
achieved anything in the world I'm not
debating you I'm using you as I say that
they're the canvas I'm painting my
troupe on their campus I'm talking to
the people the million or so people were
following me I'm showing the million or
so people because if people follow me
who feel what I feel but they're shy and
they don't know how to speak on it and I
think that the GOP the Trump
administration they won you know and
they won
surprisingly because look I'm not a
liberal I don't consider myself a
liberal I don't consider myself a
progressive but I was [ __ ] naive
because I didn't think Trump had a
chance and my working-class friends I
got a friend said bird he's a comedian I
hope he's listening now he's a plumber
and he told me his politic is the same
as mine [ __ ] with Donald Trump
lady Tony's and Trump is gonna win and I
was like what do you mean I'm like he's
like hee-hee
because I as a performer had the luxury
of travel in a world and Terra learning
my audiences to how I want them I people
pay to see me they want to hear what I
got to say I don't have to be around
people I don't agree with right ever you
know this guy is a plumber he has to go
work with working-class people he may
not agree based on different backgrounds
so he saw it he was closer to the ground
then I went I had to pause and reflect
usually I'm more on point what the
people are dealing with I didn't think
Trump had a chance turns out he had more
than a chance isn't it amazing how many
people in show business and this is like
anyone comedians rappers actors people
just hang out with a like-minded right
yeah and cannot bow and so what happens
is when people vote for Trump like I
they mistreated as everyone who voted
for Trump is a redneck and a terrible
person and it's like that's just not
they're just regular people and I
decided until you lose again in four
years well that mind says you know to
that to that connect state um you know
the fact of the matter is Trump from the
time the first time Trump was in the New
York Times it was for red lining was for
not red lining but the child of red
lining was for housing discrimination
him and his father
a suit for housing discrimination
against people of color several times
Fred Trump was arrested at a Klan rally
Donald Trump's record on race he tried
to get to Central Park five killed his
record on race he talked about he talked
about I only like Jews counting my money
blacks are lazy you know his record on
race is is he's definitely an enabler of
racism and the racist lie that Obama is
somehow Kenyan born a Muslim a Muslim
born a Kenyan like he pushed that for
eight years and that's that's a racist
racist thing but I will say that people
I am famous for calling people who vote
for Trump races online if I do it all
the [ __ ] tough but it's more accurate
to say that people who vote for Trump I
think enable racism more than their
actual races and I say that as someone
who enables racism like I live in
America racism esthetical I pay tax and
I live here just by the nature of me
living in a racist system I enable
racism any time I call a black man
[ __ ] I enable racism any time I
participate in any stereotype I label
racism sorry enough you talk about as a
rapper saying that and there's the big
controversy about Bill Maher I by the
way we have to wrap up soon before we do
I want to plug your day for the color
about five minutes all we do okay okay
and you're going on tour and you're
going to be performing at Ozzie fest - I
didn't plug that I don't get cut off
without giving you your power
ok out of conversation I don't like I
don't like to do that all the sudden
rappers who still use it it's almost
like the what the you can't have a word
where there's a different penalty for
different artists it just to me it
doesn't work because once it's this word
then it's going to be that word and then
this can be that word and who who's
gonna be the arbiter of when it's
appropriate and when it's not okay well
let me I would definitely one address
that does it fit it cuz I can't I can't
do such an interesting discussion I kept
going on from the point um I know we
finished that story about me guess
yesterday yeah we got forgot I'm spacing
out okay so the word [ __ ] I wrote an
essay with Piers Morgan asked that
similar question a couple years ago and
I wrote a response is called [ __ ]
please why do you want to say it so bad
anyway and so as I really wrote that out
because because it's such a deep issue I
wrote an essay about us so I encourage
anyone who's interested to Google quali
[ __ ] please read the essay because I'm
probably more eloquent than what I'm
about to say to you now but there
history the word is it started from
slave owners in the south not being able
to say Negro which is Spanish word so
they stayed [ __ ] and it goes back to
what I was saying about black not being
valuable so a [ __ ] was the least
valuable thing you can be there's a
history that comes with that it comes
with beating it comes with raping it
comes with torturing comes with hanging
lynching castration if someone was
called a [ __ ] the chances are you
might get hung so there's no history
there's no history with that word
there's no history equivalent and for
white people Louie does a great bit
about being white we talked about Oh
take me back in the days of owning
slaves and people I can't get mad at
cracker because it's not associated with
any real oppression right
so when [ __ ] is co-opted if the worst
thing you could be was a [ __ ] then a
black person was defiant against that
system and say well imma be the scariest
[ __ ] you could ever ever be you know
saying so I think Ice Cube when he went
to Bill Marshall and I like Bill Moore I
watch a show I don't like everything he
says but I'm a family and him a line on
a lot of things um Ice Cube was very
accurate I totally did I totally
disagree with him yeah it's why I wanted
with you it with with I see yes okay
yeah I think I think when Ice Cube said
was exactly exactly right is that if
we're talking about fairness and
equality well it's not fair you can say
the word well yeah that may not seem
fair but that we're talking about
feelings and emotions we're not talking
about reality because sleep was not fair
as oppression the oppression flows one
way it flows from the oppressor to the
oppressed so we're dealing with system
systemic oppression like we could trade
and the stare and I could have like
stereotypically great credit and you
could be able to say [ __ ] I would take
that trade any and Chris Rock did a
great bit about that too and that's all
accurate but a guy like Ice Cube who has
made a living saying what he wanted and
speaking freely about anything he wants
without penalty shouldn't be telling
somebody else I was not without penalty
or unfair penalty I'm Sarah penalty
right arm should not be telling somebody
else what's appropriate like it's not a
word that I've necessarily all you want
to say the word so bad you just don't
want it to be a career-ending moment
it's like what Bill Maher did you just
did a dumb joke and then
the sudden people oh my god we can't
like people are shocked that somebody
would say it well I was annoyed
mentality with bill I don't think that
was a career-ending thing with him the
reason it wasn't a career-ending thing
for him is because people have been
critical they'll bill more about his
atheism and about he focuses in my
opinion a lot a lot more in Islam and he
doesn't other religions but her but but
he keeps consistent with his atheism
people are very critical about that Bill
Maher is also showing solidarity on a
lot of social issues so because he saw
sounds airing a lot of social issues
that that it had pacted black people he
I don't think that was a career in a
moment for him but IceCube didn't say he
couldn't say it what Ice Cube said is
that there's consequences and what was
happening right now with this free
speech movement it's got Jeremy
Christian he was showing about free
speech rallies free speech rallies
throwing up neo-nazi swoops and what you
have is you have white supremacist neo
Nazis who are the fringe of the
conservative just like your black
supremacist on the fringe we have Nazis
and noise the premise on the fringe but
they're now becoming mainstream to
people like Richard Spencer and people
like this we're now saying I have the
right to say whatever I want well
America free speech is protected and
Richard Spencer gets out and says
something that seems Nazi ish somebody
might come and punch him in the face
the person who punch them in the face
got arrested which means which dispenser
didn't get arrested for what he sent and
what he said with some white genocide
Nazi type [ __ ] he didn't get arrested
for that you know why because hate
speech free speech all that whatever you
want to say in America so loud it's
allowed what's not allowed as you can't
punch the money in a face for saying
right correct and so when the person
gets punched in the face for saying it
the person who gets arrested gets punch
in the face that means that free speech
is protected so what is these people
who's saying their free speech is under
attack saying it's not under attack what
they're saying is I just want the right
to be a dick I want the right to be a
jerk like this guy like people like Milo
I want to be able to say racist bigoted
sexist things [ __ ] up things I don't
want anyone to get mad I don't want to
get punched in the face I don't want
nobody doodle at me like to my might oh
[ __ ] I think it I think that they don't
want people don't want a penalty for it
and I tell you why again mile is an
extreme example content extreme stuff
but we can give you a penalty besides
the government somebody comes and
punches you in the face
it fires from your job on that that's
the Pell job the job is private see the
job is not required to keep you on it
they don't like what you say correct you
can go out in the street with a makeup
or not evidence
spirit of free speech is not about
losing your gig because what's offensive
that's an obviously offensive thing you
stand up and you say I believe in gay
marriage where if the head of
chick-fil-a says I want you fired for
saying that because I think it's
disgusting he can he can but that's not
to me that's where the issue gets kind
of hairy and that's not what free speech
is supposed to be it's not supposed to
be if I say something and popular but
are we talking about free speech and
free market because free market dictates
capitalism is king and the bottom line
is King and capitalism a king and bottom
line is King then the boss has the right
to fire somebody for any reason but the
boss is firing people a lot of times
because of pressure from a special
interest group and not really capitalism
capitalism is just hey if we I don't
like what you're going to do I'm not
going to purchase your product if people
are just threatening because they didn't
like what you said capitalism supply and
demand the special interest groups are
allowed to voice themselves in a
democracy I think special interest is
free speech so they're allowed to Daryl
out at the end this free speech free
speech can't be fought for only when
it's on your side oh great
yes so a special interest have the same
free speech as at the chick-fil-a guy
who says I'm a closed on Sundays they
absolutely have the free speech but
they're trying to pressure some but I
like chick-fil-a a lot man and I stopped
eating it and I plastic dietary that
starts the [ __ ] free market right
there just don't eat it like if I don't
agree to something don't eat it but
they're trying to get people constantly
shut down for things they say and it's
one of these sounds like the Boston Tea
Party to me I mean this country started
a protest dissent is very patriotic and
you have to you have to reel in the
powerful people
the voice of the people that the country
was set up those men weren't per find
and fathers more perfect they were
misogynist they hated gay people they
didn't want women to vote they had they
kept waves but what they were studied
and they studied they studied
governments in they study history and
they created a system of democracy look
NPR which is NPR posted the declaration
independence on Twitter Trump supporters
lost a [ __ ]